hey what's up guys my name is a cheddar
welcome to episode 72 of game
programming so today we're gonna take a
look at um cluttering up this whole
entity removal system and hopefully
storing projectiles in a good place so
right now what happens is um well we
already juicing the size of a projectile
list but what happens when we actually
make a projectile is we add it into an
entity system so let me try and find the
code to prove to you guys that I'm not
lying
right so I'm guessing that should be in
mob yeah okay so we add a projectile
here and you can see here that we
actually level dot add pay so if we go
to level don't add you can see that it
actually adds an entity to a list so a
quick way of fixing that honestly like
there's multiple ways of doing this and
I'll probably cover both but one way is
just having public void AK add
projectile and then like projectile pay
alright and then actually having a list
here as well that holds reject Isles and
then in you know in the future when you
get to optimizing or whatever you can
remove it obviously because you're just
not gonna need it I mean you you be
sorry if I remove it I mean remove one
of the lists because obviously right now
we've got two projectile is one in the
level class and one in the UM mob class
and you know in the future you could
synchronize the two and make sure that
cuz there's kind of a bad practice to
have to look the same lists in different
classes especially if they're literally
the same so there's that but um you know
projectiles don't add pay all right and
then if we just scare away into where we
actually rendered the entities which is
all right here we can we could also add
a um you know for sure child size
literally the same just projectiles
right okay pretty simple and obvious
over here in oh we have we after the
same thing for update as well I believe
entities no interests easy up there to
get off data consider yeah
up there right so we've done both update
and render for both for the a for the
projectiles and now we have to do really
is in mob which is instead of level that
ad pay we can just level to that
projectile okay alright and so what that
essentially doesn't separates lists now
that's all cool but it still doesn't fix
our problem because you know the thing
that's kind of going on here is when we
actually exceed the range you know we
remove it from the list with the list
that we're removing it from is obviously
you know the mob lists if we control
click on that we'll get we get taken
over here and so now we kind of say okay
well you know what we've got an instance
of level accessible to our mob class
right and you know theoretically that
does make sense because um well because
a mob has have a level to it so you know
in our hierarchy it makes sense and we
do actually have any instance variables
let's get rid of this completely and
what we can do here is just put well
leveled our projectiles so we can
actually get rid of that completely and
over here in player you know we've got
this whole thing going on here we can
actually just hit up leveled up
projectile size yeah and we'll have to
make this public okay now that's one way
of doing it I'll probably just give this
private though make a getter for it so
public list projectile get projectiles
and then we can simply just return that
list of projectiles which is called
projectiles yeah that's one way of doing
it so if we come over here um we just
hit up level dough to get projectiles
doll size yeah and then same thing here
yeah again so we could do that I never
hear in mob does one more thing and that
is the size of everything else let's
just print that out so let's just check
out what this looks like and you can see
now that works perfectly because he's
got this little black thing in front of
them
because um obviously we set the range to
be really low so if I go back to the
range real quick for you fellas um
where's that uh know being wizard
projectile so the range right now is
like - what's so that's 20-hour Arkell
so we are getting some range here but
still we're cuttin off pretty pretty
early so let's maybe set it up to a
hundred all right sweet yeah so
occasionally actually we're kind of
getting oh yeah yeah sorry um we did
slight miscalculation here we've got a
tech sergeant sort of why I actually saw
the comments to that the other day but I
didn't talk about it sorry this is
supposed to be ex Arjun so if we do that
again we should have a stream that
pretty much breaks off when ratios are
so important which is arranged of it
okay wait so that's you know that's
probably the way that we're gonna do now
I said I'll show you guys another way
but the other way would really literally
be the same because um it would just say
that it would just treat a projectile as
as if it's in the entities list and I'm
just thinking right now I might want to
keep them separate right I might just
want to keep two different lists one for
projectiles and one for entities just
because well just because just because I
think it might be better in the future
but yeah that's pretty much how that
works
next time we'll probably cover let's
just quickly just play around with this
because it's fun I'll show you guys in
more detail um yeah you can sit out
there and let's maybe set wizard to
actually about two hundred okay
now this is what I wanted to show you
guys if we put a speed to 100 obviously
limit how fast every guy tells go so if
I shoot these you see they actually
disappear when they hit the range 200
yeah you saw that so let's do that again
these guys are traveling and they all
disappear when they hit that range
okay now what we could do is actually
add a random range so if and I probably
will do that maybe not for this maybe
some weapons might want to the public
will just bill protects the final round
and Moran and Michael's me random yeah
just because and we're declaring it
final by the way because we're not gonna
have more than one instance of this is
going to be al it's going to be constant
here this should never change
let's go and do here so we'll set the
speed to random dot next int I'm sorry
rather not not speed range so random dot
next int and we'll probably just leave
it it you know 150 plus oh no no 100
plus 150 so in otherwise range the range
will be between 150 and 250 she's pretty
good so if we just do this what you'll
see is these guys will kind of disappear
at you know random instances so it won't
be as as uniform yeah they'll kind of
randomly disappear which is kind of cool
so that's an idea as well and if we just
have the range or something like you
know kind of smaller and maybe this paid
off just a bit you know
dollars disappear random instances let's
get rid of this completely and that kind
of looks a bit more organic right so
yeah so that's one way to do it
I probably will leave it at 200 though
and the speed back up to fall and you
can set this up pretty high as well like
there could be some seriously fast
moving things you like bullets in the
future I'm and just all of that yeah so
this is so fast you can't actually see
they're moving because we're on the
updating them 60 times a second but yeah
okay up there yeah not much else to say
yeah let's leave this at 4 there because
I was cool anyway
that's it next time we'll probably cover
rate of fire so that we can slow down
the rate at which we fire these
particles all these projectiles so yeah
anyway I hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of game programming if you did
please hit the like button I'll see
guys next time with a new episode guys
you